so here um we have a publication about
this effort to try to
make a single cell type transcriptomics
map of human tissue so you can see that
this is
um from july 2021 so a very recent
article and you can see here
[Music]
uh the humancell atlas.org right and
this is something that
we can
actually look at let's try to understand
because we have this capability to
sequence uh you know individual cells uh
we would like to create a reference that
is a as comprehensive as possible of
human tissues and so this particular
effort
is trying to create an open access atlas
that will allow researchers to explore
the expression of human protein coding
genes in
192 individual cell type clusters
and then an expression specificity
classification was performed to
determine the number of genes elevated
in each cell type allowing comparisons
with bulk transcriptomic data right so
there's a lot more data already that
exists on bulk rna-seq
and in this case we would like to take
these single cell data and increase the
kind of specificity or the detail of
this bulk
and so they took
you can see here both imaging
bulk rnaseq and single cell data to try
to dissect all these tissues into
individual types of cells that then we
could reference
and understand
uh specific genes that are elevated or
down regulated so let's actually take a
look at this um
this is uh
the place that you would go to
find the actual data and you can read
here a lot of the sources of the data
that they
used and also you can see some of the
examples of the data and the examples of
the data
are possible to view and visualize and
so that's what we'll do today what we'll
do today is
these collections because all of these
are going to be collections of data and
let's explore what does it actually look
like so if you go with me to this second
link
you can actually select many different
um
many different
types of tissues but let's just take a
look at here specifically what what can
we find so when we think of types of
cells right we typically say okay well
there's neuronal cells
there is
uh you know oligodendrocytes there's
microglia macrophages etc and you can
see here what in reality we find right
in reality
this type of analysis
helps us increase the dimension so for
example you can see oligo 1
5 two six four three so there's
six different types of oligo cells right
and you can see here
that you know if you actually select
they mix
a lot between themselves right these are
not clusters that are you know always
very very clearly defined i mean you can
see that all of them are right here but
they're also found right here so a lot
of these types of references
give us the strongest signal that we
have not all of them are so clearly
differentiated from each other right
some of them are but not all of them
okay so here for example
endothelial cells
microglia right but but some of these
other types which are probably the
majority of the cells start to be more
spread out and more complex right so the
more we want to define these specific
cells we can group them into larger kind
of collections of different subtypes but
also within each
group this larger group will find
more and more specific trends and
patterns
okay so this is healthy tissue okay so
remember this is um an attempt to map
out all of the different cell types
different uh ball card ac data imaging
data and you will always see the
differences in morphology and kind of
the
different phenotypic part of that data
as well
but then you want to go deeper and
deeper and try to understand well what
are the differences within this you know
big collection of cells that we call
neurons right obviously there are many
different types of neurons
okay so the next thing that we want to
look at is look at some examples from
disease
okay so
here we saw these are healthy tissues
now let's look at disease so this is a
collection of data
that was taken from
all of the you know possible data sets
that are available on tumors so
in cancer we would like to now
understand how different types of
cancers which we know are primarily
by tissue type right so when you have
breast cancer and lung cancer the
differences between those tumors are
going to be associated with the type of
cancer lung or breast
but now we would like to understand how
these cancer cells differentiate within
a particular subtype
okay so this is again uh something that
you can find i'll post the links here as
well as well
this is a project by some chinese
university uh where they basically
re-annotated right they collected a lot
of metadata uh meta-analysis sorry of uh
data sets uh that came from uh geo from
pcga etc right and they tried to
understand you know again what is the
relationship between what we know from
bulk and asic to single cell so again
let's take a look here at one such
example
so here we'll take
lung tumor micro environment and we'll
try to understand
here
what can we learn about you know a
condition like cancer which is a complex
condition that we can actually uh try to
interpret biologically so what i'll do
is i'll go to this link again on your
own free time you can explore all kinds
of other types of data that are
available here
and you'll find that you know a lot of
these are just collections of data sets
that others have published
okay so
here you will find a typical analysis
workflow and we will in our second
session today learn about the different
steps of analysis and how to actually
perform them but in my session i'm going
to ignore some of these basic things and
i'm going to move on to kind of like you
know what do we learn from these
collections
so again you will find here we have some
dimensionality reduction with t-sne and
umap
you can see that umap is typically going
to be a little bit better
making the separation greater between
the larger groups but actually if you
compare the two uh you know it's obvious
that both are useful for example here i
have a greater resolution of this mixed
cluster and here this mix cluster is
very condensed together right
so if you scroll down
let's just take a look at this chart
right here and let's see so again this
is the tumor micro environment what is
the tumor micro environment the micro
environment is like the layer between
the tumor that kind of created its own
hyper growth aggressive this kind of
like uncontrollable
tumor that is hurting everything and the
normal tissue right in between there's
this area that we call the tumor micro
environment typically it has a lot of
immune cells right so when something
like that happens the natural reaction
of the organism is to address it by
putting there the offensive right and
saying let's first of all quarantine
this whole place and then let's kill
them and so you see here uh t cells uh
you can see here macrophages and and
other kinds of cells right and and
specifically you can see here if you
click right here that there's about
three percent of malignant cells right
why is this important
well this is important because a typical
approach for
treating cancer is reducing the tumor
size through chemotherapy and then
trying to cut out surgically
whatever we can that makes that a
potential for new growth right and so
typically
that does not include all of the micro
environment because it's difficult the
micro
environment is integrated in a healthy
tissue it's difficult to separate it but
that is the problem the problem is that
you have three percent
malignant cells that are inside
infiltrating the tumor micro environment
so if you think about cancer and the
stages of cancer it's all about uh this
proliferation and kind of going beyond
the boundary so containing the two in a
well-defined boundary is stage one and
as it goes beyond that boundary that's
when your stages continue and eventually
metastasis is that they're way beyond
right the actual environment and so this
is the problem right here these
malignant cells now you can see here
this is just counts of cells
if you scroll down this is now
differential gene expression right so
now we would like to ask well what are
the differentially expressed genes
in these different clusters so these are
the different clusters
and let us try to compare them and
identify differences between the
clusters and here's what we have right
so these are gene
gene names these are types so these are
the clusters that we have so let's find
here
those
malignant cells right here you see this
is the malignant cells right so this is
this cluster right here
and here we have a group of genes that
are unique
to this cluster right
so we can find these specific genes and
we can say okay whenever i look at lung
cancer let me look for these specific
genes and i will be able to find some
cells that are specific to this
malignant type so where do we find them
here here you can see i can find them
malignant right here malignant cells so
they are very different and that is
because if i could
look at the tissue and say here's the
group of malignant cells they're not
going to be grouped together they could
be spread out right but i can now
identify them and that is very important
okay so this is an example again we have
four cancer and you can take a look at
other examples as well
now let's take a look
at another major condition another major
condition that has been you know on the
top of everybody's mind
is sars cove two so here's a collection
again of all of the data sets
that are available for
um
19 and i'll paste a link to this here as
well
okay
here we can see how we are trying to map
out the uh
disease in different tissues right and
you start seeing these umaps that look
like this which is now a lot more
difficult to interpret right because
there's so much overlap here
but essentially what we can do is we do
a comparison like this
and in this comparison
we have
it's a single data set so again remember
that there's a lot of variability in the
data sets but here is the basic approach
let's take some covid19 patients
some healthy patients and let's try to
count how many cells of different type
do i have
and so what's what stands out to you
in this comparison right here
what difference do you notice most
between these different
groups of samples
who would like to
take a look at that and and suggest the
differences that you observe in this
chart so again
okay so julia is saying endothelial
lymphatic cells higher
how did she get to that idea right let's
take a look so first of all we're
looking at colors
inside each color box we have number of
cells
and the colors are actually annotated
down here below
so here she's saying endothelial
lymphatic cells okay so this is this
purplish car
right here
is amplified in covid and almost doesn't
exist right maybe right here almost does
not exist
in healthy patients
you can also say the biggest difference
that i observe is this orange color that
is much less in covid compared to
healthy so here what is the orange i go
back over here alveolar right so what
kind of
what kind of
tissue is this this is lung tissue so
what are we seeing we're seeing that
covidon 19
is killing off right eliminating cells
that are alveolar
you can see here expanding types of
cells so for example red right so here i
can see an expansion of red cells what
are these red cells these are natural
killer t cells
okay so
we we kind of now can have a direct
biological interpretation well we know
that cobit replicates in alveoli
primarily
and then we see the natural killer t
cells are coming and attacking them
right and that is immediately clear from
this particular study and that's an
exciting thing to see because it really
confirms you know what we kind of know
intuitively
from reading these publications we see
where it's coming from and obviously
like julian noticed already a lot of
these
other types of cells have also been many
different as well right so now that
gives us an insight into what additional
questions could i ask right how could i
think about this and expand on this you
know basic level that i already know and
start asking more specific questions
okay so these are some collections just
examples you know there's also a mouse
cell atlas so a lot of work is done on
animal models right so there's a lot of
information about mice a lot of
information about human health tissues
some disease conditions as well you will
think the developmental aspect is very
interesting as well development of
different types of tissues
development of disease etc